my guest tonight is a talented comedian
and actor who has appeared in curb your
enthusiasm
the goldbergs and blackish he also
voices the character cooper
in the upcoming dreamworks animated
series trolls topia
please welcome our really good friend
thrilled he's here in person
ron funches ron hi ron thanks for being
here
oh i'm happy to be here yeah i you uh
you know you and i spent a lot of time
together we toured together
uh i always enjoy my time with you and
then
um most of these interviews that we're
doing are on zoom and then i find out
ron's actually going to come to the
theater and hang with us so you made my
day thank you
yeah well i got half a shot so i was
willing to risk it
and i was just like i want i love largo
is one of my favorite
so you yeah you've performed here at
largo
quite a bit so you know this is like
kind of a comedy mecca yeah
here and here in l.a um and
how long ago did you get started at
largo did you did you play here when you
were just starting out
when i first moved to los angeles yeah i
come to largo quite a bit and end up on
guesting on other people's shows a lot
of their end friends show and
anytime i did it i'd go like oh i feel
like i'm really good at comedy
and then i talked to flannery and he was
like oh you should book your own show
here and then we'd book it
and then we'd always cancel it because
of lack of ticket sales
is that true flan again did you it is
true
it is true what twice
no it was not because of the pandemic no
it was through lack of
but that's why he believes in me more
than the general public
right that's what i like right right
would you have to tell wou would
flanagan
call you up and go oh it's not happening
tonight
you'll not be doing a show it would
start a few days like you might want to
push it
maybe we'll wait another year until
you're a little more a little more
famous
um yeah that's how
he treated that's what he did to me and
i had like had a late night show for
years
he'd be like i don't think you're ready
for largo have you got any tape i could
look at
yes i've got 7 000 hours of tape you
could look at
now you said you got half a shot so you
got one of two shots
okay yeah i went and um there's just you
know there's lack of
just general sys anything being put
together so there was just like
if you show up wait for a couple hours
and you can get a shot and i just been
you know i'm the pretty much the
breadwinner in my family so i was like
it's important for me i had to go back
out go and do shows go and do sets and
right so i didn't want to jump in line
on anybody but if i could just wait in
line like i'm waiting in line for a
nintendo i've waited in line for
sneakers
i could wait in line for this you have
your priorities straight
as long as you've got the nintendo you
wanted and you've got the sneakers you
wanted then it's time to maybe wait in
line for a shot it was a very similar
experience
really just black people were excited
talking about what they were going to do
once they got it they were like oh i'm
going to get soup
i'm gonna get soup yeah elaine it was
real exciting to go to a diner and get
soup
i got the vaccine and now i can get soup
yes wow
she'd go sit at her spot at her counter
and go get soup
that's amazing i feel like you know it
really made me feel
a lot more optimistic and just grateful
and be like oh yeah
a lot of these people were really old
they were just like i just want to be
able to die of natural causes and
not from there it was just that i can't
wait to die of natural causes
i say that all the time that's true i
feel like that's a luxury
that's true i've always wanted to go out
in like a
something a little dramatic like a bear
attack you know like
what if the bear eats me except for a
part of the leg
and the bear is like i'm good yeah i'm
cool i'm good
and the kids are like no no no you got
to finish dad wanted
every all of him eaten he's like i
really i can't i want to leave room for
dessert
for pound cake you know i don't like
either though okay
naturally have my family be upset and
then have them like fight over my
fortune
you know i will say you're uh and i've
always noticed this about you you were
very upbeat person and
i appreciate that because i said we we
did a tour together we went to a lot of
cities we were in
you know close quarters a lot and you're
always
you seem optimistic you're you've got a
good life energy how do you maintain
that
is it tough to do like right now uh
sometimes yeah
sometimes it is tough to do when you you
can just start getting
down on i mean all of us if you look for
krills you'll find them you know you can
say
what's going wrong and and see and it's
all around you but
um i just think like this time period is
what i'm built for is because if it's
easy to be optimistic when things are
going well
just like you know when comedy and
everything was flourishing everybody was
here in town and then
as a china trouble everybody wants to
leave but like
i was i'm here i have nowhere else to go
i want to do this
and whether it's as you know
i want it to be or something different
i'll do my part to make it
better yeah be a positive that's like
that's my job
is your i have found like my kids my
kids are
my daughter's 17 my son's 15. they've
struggled a little bit because they
don't like zoom learning
and they can get down how's your son how
old is your son malcolm my son
will be 18 in april okay yeah
so how's he doing with all this he does
pretty well
he makes the kids in his class call him
king malcolm on
zoom he wears a burger king crown and
he just leans into it so it's delusions
of grandeur maybe yeah yeah
yeah if anything he's like i caused this
i no longer want to go to school so you
all come to me
i wear a crown and i just do this online
but um you know he does miss some of his
friends and things but
he's been the real trooper that's
another person that makes me optimistic
when he's just like
uh it is what it is covet 19
sucks 20 20 sucked but we just keep
going to school
right and i was like man like yeah
exactly yeah as long as he's got a
burger king crown
mm-hmm he can get it and he's excited
for his birthday he wrote his birthday
list which is
every year wait a minute this is going
to be a big one so he's going to be 18.
so that 18 is a big year once you turn
18
certain doors open to like what you're
allowed to is he very aware of that oh
he is very well he's a rule follower i
think it's part of the autism that makes
him really just focus in on rules
but he's really aware he was like oh i
turn 18
r-rated movies he has a list he's like i
want explicit cds
the next thing said adult toys which i'm
[Laughter]
does he know does he know he's not does
he know what adult toys
are i'm tired of these children toys i
want to talk to him
i truly hope he does not but you know
what it's time for him to learn
either way i did not know what an adult
toy was when i turned 18.
i did not i'm still not sure yeah that's
what your wife said
i wasn't sure i thought it was an egg
timer i didn't
she was like where did you find that it
was in your drawer
the eggs are i think ready
[Laughter]
one of the things that's been kind of
i think cool for you is that for a lot
of us
it's we need an audience and we're kind
of locked into this
one sort of narrow way of doing things
you
yes you're a very popular stand-up
comedian
but you also have been getting a lot of
voice over work
and you got this trolls gig
which is a big deal and i would think
that
that's something you can be working on
and doing
during covig because you can probably do
it during us in a safe way if it's voice
over work
yeah no it's been beautiful to have
voice acting in my life
i used to kind of be of two minds about
it because i love stand up and i
consider myself a comedian first and
foremost
and so i'd be like oh maybe if i focus
more then people would be like he's such
a brilliant stand-up
and then this pandemic happened i was
like oh no it's good this is dead now so
it's good to be a jack-of-all-trades and
just have a complex web and if
i don't think if it wasn't for trolls um
it would have been a very
much more difficult year for me and it's
just fun
it allows me to still be a child and
just be playful
and and just play around i mean i loved
it when i was in final space and you
like you got you were my dad in that
like i love being in all these different
worlds and
and playing around so i really
appreciate trolls you also have
a very distinctive voice like
you're and i think that's a real gift
which i don't know if you
liked it when you were a kid no you
didn't like it
no people always make fun of me or even
when i worked at a bank call center and
they call me ronda which we talked about
before
you had a whole other life when you were
working on a bank you did talk about
that once with me which is you worked at
a call
center and people called you rhonda
mm-hmm you lean into it you lean into it
and now it's
the fact that you can do all these cool
voices and you have well that's not true
i have one voice of different energies
that's it you're wrong sleepy or ron
excited sometimes the voice acting
people don't know that and they go
can you play this other character and
i'm like well he's gonna sound a lot
like the first one
it's gonna sound exactly like this now
the people you grew up with
are you close with any of them have you
stayed in touch with any of them are you
one of those guys that just moved on
[Laughter]
no i'm so close with some of them i have
some good friends my friend one lung
he's a really cool guy one lung yeah he
has one lung
i figured that from his nickname yeah
he'll be weird if we called him daddy
he actually has three lungs
so we call him one you know it's like
yeah it's like calling you know a tall
guy shorty you know
yeah yeah um wow he actually worked at
the bank with me and that we're still
friends and i've been
um running like a twitch channel where i
play games and stuff and he helps me run
that so
um no i staying close with some of the
people i also follow some of my high
school crushes on only fans
now which has been very enjoyable for me
only fans
the thing where that's that's the site
where women
sort of these you have classmates that
are on only fans
yeah i was like i did not know i just
had to be patient and just wait this out
[Laughter]
so these are girls you had crushes on
and now you can
take out your mastercard and uh
and and talk to them and i don't talk to
them no that'd be rude i'm married i
just look at them naked as opposed to
just a porn star who doesn't like why i
don't care about how they live or how
they're growing
why not just help my friend and their
naked
endeavors
[Laughter]
are you gonna go to ever go to a school
reunion and say oh i watch you all the
time
i've been you you've really you look
good you really look good are you gonna
do that
i don't think my wife will like that i
probably shouldn't even have mentioned
that i do this
look you haven't been married long you
gotta learn well you've just been
married a couple of months
right yes a little over six months now
i've been married 19 years and here's my
advice to you you don't tell them
everything and you never
let them watch your talk show
appearances yeah no
my wife does not watch any of my talk
show appearances because she knows i'll
say something that's horrified
i wish i had the opposite she watches
all of them and then goes why did you
say that
but i love it i love that she like only
her and my mom watch like they watch
everything i do and that's wow you know
i'm like oh yeah really
that's what that's my love language is
just you know
praising me well uh tell your mom i said
hi
and your wife i know them both but your
mom's a character
and i love meeting your mom on tour that
was really fun so please
give her my love absolutely i don't know
about love you know she's not going to
want that she's going to want me
okay then i send my love yeah she's
getting older okay
[Laughter]
she's getting older she'll accept love
now
uh all right the second season of
trollstopia premieres march 18th on hulu
and peacock
and dark web uh is it cicada
3301 yeah the title's wrong makes it
sound bad but it's
pretty good i watched it i'm really good
in it
see that's all you need to know and i
you know what
people don't say that unless it's true
because i'm here with
plenty of celebrities who i'll say oh
and you should check out so and so and
i'll say is it good they'll be like
you know you know like the people are
pretty honest so that's great
dark web cicada 3301 the word on the
street is that you're very good in it
will be available on demand this friday
march 12th which also happens to be
ron's birthday i didn't know you know
happy birthday you know how i knew
a little prompter told me
[Laughter]
ron funches best laugh in the business
thanks for being here oh it's
always a pleasure conan